Heather and I took some time to work on
our marriage in private we went to a
couples therapy retreat in Sedona and
then we got some big news do you know
why we're making pink and blue cupcake
okay
Mommy has a baby in her belly having a
baby and splitting up
fans of Teen Mom og stars Kaitlyn mol
and Tyler Baltierra have watched a long
time love's struggle in their marriage
this season you seem frustrated I'm done
with the talk and I want more of the
walk Tyler even sought the help of a
counselor there's someone asking are you
happy in your marriage I would say
absolutely not and I have for a couple
of years but in the most recent episode
the pair who have been together since
middle school dropped two major
bombshells first revealing that Kaitlyn
was pregnant again so you're gonna be a
big sister
yeah then revealing that Tyler had asked
if they could try living apart for a
month getting pregnant was very
unexpected since we still have a lot of
work to do on our relationship I was
devastated at first but now that I have
started my own therapy I'm more
comfortable with the idea when producer
sat down with the 26 year olds to ask
them about their decision Kaitlyn seemed
more reserved by jumping of joy for it
no you know you took it kind of hard
yeah or to make you feel any of your
core wounds but in that moment I did
trigger me did bring up wounds it was
scary it was sad it was hurtful things
that I've been through like like when
people say that they want to separate
they want to leave it seriously does
feel like somebody died Kaitlyn has
sought treatment for anxiety and past
traumas including a difficult
miscarriage leading to her going to
several treatment facilities on her own
and that's why it was so hard for me to
even say it because it was like I knew
it was really the possibly the worst
Hospital commit you get here Kaitlyn
later opened up to another mtv producer
noting that they have not talked divorce
and I even text him and asked him like
it is there somebody else did you
yeah we'll see like no yeah crazy think
that I hope it's like she done you know
might get my heart of heart to know but
it was just so a blindsided yeah my god
I feel like the separation thing for me
it's gonna be hard but it'd be good for
me in my house oh then I have time it's
just like really focus on me and Nova
later in the episode the couple through
a gender-reveal party and learned that
they're having another girl another girl
girls are so sassy do you only make
girls what's your problem they place
their first daughter Carly up for
adoption in 2009 before welcoming Nova
in 2015 the two celebrated their 3 year
wedding anniversary in August but have
been noticeably absent from one another
social media pages in recent months it's
always been Cate and Highgate Highgate
and I you know it just gives me each of
us some room to grow our own
[Music]
[Applause]